[Music]
trees coming at ya
you need RVs it's sort of endearing sort
of weird which is what areas are today
I'm Ann Jones the ABCs nature nerd and
today we're going to be unpacking some
viral Helios
[Music]
Oh is he playing ball this is an emu
that looks like he's been hand reared
looks like a young EMU because he's got
dark feathers see how curious he is he's
testing it with his beak because you
know like we have hands EMU's don't
that's sort of like stompy sort of
excited behavior I've sort of seen that
happen around snakes as well just so
excited by life when they're little
they're stripy and that's partially sort
of camo oh you can see a little floppy
wing yeah that they do have wings under
there they're just not very useful are
they one of the interesting things is is
they've lost flight scientists think
that what happened is they used to be
able to fly and over time they found
that running was more efficient so they
gradually lost the ability to fly and
probably in the process of doing that
became bigger as well and that's why we
see the emus that we have today which
are as tall as a man and very silly next
video more emus oh god I wonder if that
any wants to mount it you a wonder if
this is curious or it's some sort of
mating display enews don't just
necessarily bump into each other in the
desert and have sex and that's it they
have courting behaviors and it involves
all sorts of noise making and circling
each other so maybe this tourist is
getting a dirty holiday
they're all following dad how it works
in EMU world right is you get a little
bit of a dance going and then you have a
little bit of a mate and the bloke will
have already built a nest and the female
goes over and she lays a clutch of eggs
maybe 15 and then as soon as she's done
that she buggers off and from there on
it's the male who does all of the
child-rearing
he will basically sit on those eggs for
months incubating them turning them and
he won't eat and he won't drink and he
won't even poop and then when they hatch
he will look after those little chicks
sometimes they sort of just seem to take
on other EMU dad's flocks and so you'll
end up having multiple clutches like you
know of 20 or 30 little babies or
following dad Wow look at him go they
were unexamined on't they they can run
at like 50 K is an hour when they really
want to this is very typical mu
behaviour they'll often run directly in
front of the car just go off the side
you'll go cut go off this not next one
[Music]
oh dear this very unhappy email you can
see that that bird when its aggressive
it's standing up very tall making itself
big by sort of fluffing up its fluffy
feathers all over its neck and you heard
really beautiful sound in this one both
hissing which is extremely sort of
aggressive and the Bob beam which is the
emus and alien sound and it does it by
inflating an air sac and whomping it no
they rubber they why are you upsetting
that emu mate put the camera down and
get out of there there is no doubt and M
you could hurt you with those huge claws
there three-toed and their middle toe is
much much bigger
perfect for disembowelling you I mean I
haven't heard of it happening the emu
deaths that do occur and there I suppose
in an indirect way our emu deaths are
actually through road accidents because
emus have no roots it's like zero and in
fact they'll often make the exact wrong
decision when it comes to Road sense
[Music]
so that's it for this video but there
are more to watch in the how deadly
series so should be able to click on
some links and if you've got an idea for
an arm video why don't you send it in to
us or leave a comment below anyway until
next time catch you later
[Music]